I think from now on you should get
advice from me I would love advice how
do I become successful like you
and is that a real you want a real
answer yeah
cliche but it's also every question I
would like like to ask you because you
would be the right person to give that
advice um my real advice to you
um without any comedy angle
um is um kill yourself no kidding no I I
know my real advice is
my mom already gave me another one she
beat you my mom beat you this morning
um and this is the truth and there's no
um formula but you can just see it like
when you see Jesse Johnson you know
Jesse yeah yeah you know she was you
know a parking lot girl door person of
The Comedy Store but the first time I
met her there was just something about
her
and you can just tell
instinctually I have I feel like I have
that instinct and I feel that about you
and um what I want to say to you is that
as long as you don't quit because that's
if you quit it'll never happen yeah
right and it's so [__] weird about
life and if you're committed to one
thing also don't stretch yourself you
know when people I had a friend that
goes oh I'm in a band I act I do comedy
and I paint and he would put all this
energy into all those and I always tell
them they focus on one thing yeah if you
focus on one [__] thing and you don't
quit what happens is the community I
mean starts looking at you in a
different way
um they look oh she's never gonna go
away she's a real comedian right and
she's one of us right and what happens
is people rise together
people pull each other up pull each
other like for instance even you sitting
here right now
um if I had a TV show and um there was a
specific part that I think that you
would be great in you would be at the
top of my list already right but if you
weren't doing comedy right and I never
ran into you and I didn't know anything
about you that would never happen right
so just stay in it focus focus like I
know earlier in your career you would do
things like shove like candy bars like
up your butt and like basically do these
extreme things like do you suggest that
Zhao Ying stays wild in that same way no
candy bars no candy bars because that's
my thing that's my thing that's stealing
no um what I'm saying is no I mean I did
those things because
um I'm just a weirdo yeah yeah I mean it
has nothing to do with anything I mean I
just like you know my butt's got to eat
you know what I mean
yeah yeah
yeah yeah I know yeah I've done
something I've been farting on people
that I don't recommend that but what I'm
saying is that never change your comedy
you know be you know it's like I
remember
um people saying um you should wear a
suit I heard people tell me you should
wear overall don't wear makeup because
you look like you are trying to send me
a house you should look like a real
comedian the girls should be like a like
not glamorous I mean like I'm from the
dumpster I'm in the world every day yeah
until I die no no no no no no no no you
do what you want to do man yeah I want
to look good and if somebody says you
swear too much or they say that like you
know
um you're too crap don't listen to
anybody you just stay yourself man
because it's like over the years they're
like you're not gonna make it because I
mean what
who I love
I know I know him yeah we like each
other I love him he's one of the
funniest stand-ups on planet Earth I
think he's a [__] beast and him and I
are very good friends and what I'm about
to share with you right he's probably
not gonna like me saying right but I'm
gonna share it okay I didn't know many
many years ago this is probably 20 years
ago
and he he go he saw my act and I was
like talking about like jerking off and
you know what I mean and just weird you
know I mean just that kind of humor and
um I swore a lot and you know I mean and
um everything was about my dad or Asian
and um he goes after you
um after you get off I want to talk to
you in the back of the Laugh Factory and
he had a conversation with him and he
goes you're never gonna get on The
Tonight Show with that act and I go
I did The Tonight Show
and he goes oh well you're never going
to be on a TV show with that act I go
I'm on a TV show
and he goes oh don't mind me then
and that was the end see why he doesn't
want you to tell that story
[Laughter]
about his name
yeah bleep out his name because I know
him he's crazy and we're gonna have a
fight right and then you're gonna record
it and he's one of those guys like why'd
you say this and then [__] play it
back to me all right but that actually
happened and it's like yeah I just did
what I did and a lot of people aren't
gonna like it but some people are okay
you're gonna be fine yes all right thank
you that's amazing advice yeah have you
done the road yet or no yeah I'm touring
I just got back from from New York I did
a one week in New York I'm touring where
uh 20 April 23rd and the cops almost
sold out I think we're at 300 tickets
wow in San Francisco yes Cubs yeah I
know carbs I've been in comedy I know
what the [__] it is she's like that's a
tough room to sell man